Hello,
I'm Justin and welcome to today's episode of fire of learning.
This episode is centered around Google translate.
My question with this episode is how effective is Google translate at
translating sentences from one language to another?
And I asked this and curiosity in regards to the threat to human translation,
by the advent of technology,
has many professions are threatened by technology,
especially in the 21st century.
So how effective is it?
How accurate is it?
And we would tell explore this and this episode by using two languages in which
I am professional enough,
at least to notice mistakes.
And so we're going to use French and Latin.
So to begin we will translate offers about 91 out of 6,000 or 7,000 languages in
the world.
And that's actually not too bad.
That's more languages then I speak.
So begin with a simple French sentence.
Say,
I,
I have,
I have a friend who can do this.
Um,
well
they're missing a liaison right there.
And I saw it in the beginning.
I don't know what happened to it.
But in French,
two vowels cannot often touch says is your Enemy Cup of fair?
Keep Perla Fair.
It should be Jay on the meat.
Keep putting a fair.
So it's not too far.
It's actually somewhat understandable.
But there are simple,
there's a simple grammatical error.
So
let's do French to English and you'll have to excuse my computer is in French.
These are the correct languages.
Um,
how does it work with the verb?
Uh,
Marsha.
So Marsha means to walk and we'll run it through some tenants is and see how it
does.
So this is just an infinitive.
Let's say you walked to Marsha Fed.
Okay.
Correct.
Let's make it future to marsh share.
Ah,
you will tread.
That's changing the verb,
but it's the same meaning let's make it conditional.
Too much.
Sherrie,
you would walk not bad.
Um,
let's make it has to Marsha is isn't perfect.
You walked.
That's accurate and
that's impressive.
But French is probably one of the closest languages and English currently spoken
throughout the world.
Popularly let's move to a language a little bit more different,
but still somewhat similar to English,
which is as a fore mentioned Latin.
Now the fun thing about when is it doesn't have a word for a or the,
and it has a,
but six cases might,
yeah.
Nominative genitive date of gives it an Ableton live and Vocativ yes,
six cases
and they inflict nouns and adjectives and so forth for their meaning.
They don't,
it's much more structured and that sense in English is,
so let's say
a man should have a beer,
this is not something a Roman would say,
but perhaps a German or a carrot or a gall would get on Google translate to tell
the Roman this.
Um,
well,
that's not correct.
This says,
no,
no one should have,
no one should be a bearded man.
You could translate that as,
and um,
that's pretty much the opposite of what I put in.
It should be a,
if we're using the word Homo,
homo,
Tibet barbata said,
that's close enough.
That means a man should be bearded.
Um,
well
let's say
you,
Julius,
Julius Caesar and veins,
Raul,
uh,
well it doesn't seem to recognize a verb invades.
And for some reason it puts the nominative form,
which is the subjects for Gall Inbetween Julius Caesar's name.
Okay.
That is obviously an issue because it is not as male name and it offers no
accusative.
It should be Yuliya [inaudible].
I don't know the word for invade.
I believe
pet Tierra means attack.
So Uli is Kaiser.
Golly,
I'm,
it should be something along those lines.
So Google translate's not working out pretty well with the lab,
but I want to do a final test.
I want to put a sentence through multiple languages and Google translate and
then translate it back to English to see how it survives through the filters are
not the filters,
the other languages.
So let's,
let's see.
Um,
let's say something like,
my name is Justin.
I am recording a youtube
video.
I asked,
cause the question,
hello,
does Google should be capitalized trends late
work efficiently.
So let's run this sentence through several languages and see how it comes back
to us.
So starting with Latin.
Alright,
Noah steel,
Latin two French,
two French,
two
Korean,
Korean to
Danish.
Danish to
Punjabi,
20 Javi
to
check,
check two,
two,
two chihuahuas to
Arabic.
Arabic to
do Japanese ship.
Why Shepherd?
Nikki?
Okay.
Japanese.
The Chinese.
Okay.
Oh,
what?
Oh my bad Chinese too.
Russian.
Russian too.
Irish.
Very Long Day and Irish back to English.
And we end up with the sentence in the original sentence was,
my name is Justin.
I'm recording youtube video.
I asked the question,
does Google translate work efficiently?
And we ended up after several languages reaching,
my name is Justin.
I think I saw this letter.
Make sure that the expression,
obviously running the sentence through several languages in Google translate is
a nightmare.
And
it's not very likely that someone will ever have the need to run it through
several languages like that.
But if it ever,
if a need ever arose,
it would not.
And well,
so the conclusion is Google translate is a fairly efficient system,
but it makes very simple grammatical errors.
Yeah.
That often do not take the meaning of the sentence,
but it definitely can,
as we saw with what,
and it can change the entire meeting of the symptoms,
or you can end up with some nonsense such as this.
So that's all I have for you today.
Um,
thank you for watching.
I would encourage,
in fact,
to learn,
I know that language,
rather than rely on technology,
no matter how advanced it becomes.
Okay.
And,
uh,
that's all I have.
So thank you for watching.